absolutely we are right now with the
sole leader in the junior section Arthur
first of all congratulations just an
incredible game it was a matter of
preparation in this one you caught him
out of the opening and he started urine
very quickly tell us a bit about this
opening preparation of you yeah so
basically I knew he plays in Niger I
didn't want to go into it um Bishop B5 I
saw he play Knight D7 once against the
other Arthur
um so I knew he wanted a game
um I think this G6 line you have to like
know it straight down really know it
yeah because E5 is the most testing and
if you don't it's it's it's trouble for
black and he immediately went into yeah
yeah instead of D takes E5
my preparation was Knight takes E5
Knight takes it yeah okay Knight takes
and 90 seconds 97 Knight takes F7
the computer this computer says plus six
but my stronger computer back home says
it's equal Bishop takes yeah Bishop
takes D4 this is hard to find Bishop
takes F2 King H1 Rook takes d8
Bishop G5
Knight F6 Bishop C4 deep stuff yeah King
G7 Rook D2 and then you have to find D5
which is just like insane like
impossible yeah no no not D5 here Bishop
C5 rookie one and then D5 okay otherwise
the positions just collapse yes and once
she's once he started thinking at this
point you knew that yeah you will
probably have the upper hand yeah
and uh you did just that and I have to
say I really like this
idea of yours of G4 G5 oh yeah I think
you missed this
um if you could go back to one of the
other critical moments after B6
I mean we both for like a few minutes
thought like black was equalizing but I
think he missed this queen F4 idea which
is just like if you provoke E5
the D6 squared comes weak I didn't think
of queen of short but I thought it was
just better for one you're just getting
them exactly yeah
um but yeah even in this end game I
thought of Bishop E3 here instead of G4
which computer says the top move I think
they're kind of interchangeable I think
so too yeah yeah no I really like G4
from a practical perspective it just
feels like you're posing more problems
for him
Bishop C6 it's also a move that shows
confidence somewhat right
because you are weakening your king a
little bit and you have to calculate
quite precisely and he collapsed
immediately after yeah Arthur you've
been having quite the tournament so far
tell us a bit about your routine or what
do you do during the day do you call
your coach what do you do you have a
coach no I don't have a coach so I just
prep by myself but
yeah I've been just I mean I do prep go
to sleep prep when I wake up watch a
little TV in between
um that's pretty much it yeah keep it
simple and it's definitely working how
do you see your chances to get to that
elusive title
um I don't know I mean like it's it's
fine right now at least I think Abby has
a chance tomorrow so I mean there's
plenty of people that can catch up
plenty of uh just to be played in the
last couple of rounds congratulations
for your Victory we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
and Kate you have a question yeah so you
have a very successful year you have you
are a Grandmaster elect Right
congratulations for that as well uh
what's been happening with you this year
that it's so successful
um honestly I've been asking the same
question myself I honestly don't know
I've been stuck around like 24.50 for
like two years
mainly because I've been focusing on
non-chess related things
um but this summer like I played like I
went to Europe right after school and
got my final two Norms there and then
got over 2500 which was you know a
confidence boost and that definitely
helped in this tournament
so far at least
Arthur inquiring minds want to know you
said uh I've got a stronger computer
than this one tell our viewers what
computer you have I mean this is whereby
yeah sir this is just stockfish 14. this
is yeah
I have stockfish 15. I know a 16 came
out but I've yet to buy that one yet
and uh your your laptop do you use a
specific uh video card on your laptop
for your engine
I honestly don't know
but it's it's it's been working so far
so well that's all I need keep up the
good work and congratulations and two
rounds to go uh so yeah Championship
rounds Dead Ahead well done
I sounded like a techie but I really
knew what I was talking about who was
that guy yeah